so out of the gate what was it that
initially attracted you to the idea of
doing like a hidden camera
gorilla prank style comedy what was
attractive about that and what was
challenging about that
i know when you put it like that
i think it was just that you know
honestly the challenge of it
and um you know i i had i
you know knew i had watched uh eric's
show on adult swim and
and was a big fan and um i thought the
script was really funny and
i i just like the whole conceit of um
putting these two guys in this world
with real people
and um these crazy situations and seeing
what happens
so it um it was a comedy but it was sort
of like a
comedy on steroids you know it was
really it just seemed like a really fun
challenge so did you uh at any point go
through like
a training period and how to perform in
this style or like a boot camp or with a
specific audition
[Music]
yeah you know i wish there had been a
boot camp no um
there was no boot camp but the the
screen test was
um was pretty unusual
um they just told me to show up at the
glendale galleria
in los angeles and um uh
we had like a five minute discussion
about a
situation a fake prank that we were
pulling on an employee at that worked at
the
men's express store
on the lower level and it was
you know it was literally like just
being thrown into the fire which i think
is the best way to do it with this sort
of stuff and
um you know they had a couple different
versions of what they wanted to do but
they had someone
filming it and um it was the director
and i
and it was i think that was a really
smart thing to do because that was the
tone of the whole
shoot it was like are you ready let's
let's go
it was like a very quick sort of just
jump in
um so you don't really have time to to
mess it up thinking about it
you know i love that what were the
specifics of that prank what did you
have to do
i think that the scenario was that i
i remember now they um the director was
pretending to be my
like long-term boyfriend who i had
caught cheating on me
and i found him shopping i think
either for himself or for his girlfriend
at the express and confronted him in
like an all-out
you know you cheated on me what the hell
sort of situation but what happened was
one of the women who worked at the store
um i guess it had a similar situation so
she ended up
bless her heart she ended up coming up
and like come you know hugging me
and comforting me even though it was a
completely
false situation but um so that was that
was really nice
that's the whole thing about the movie
is that people really are um
so kind i really found that in shooting
the movie
you know on the streets of atlanta
people are just like
people were so willing to jump in and
and help
because they thought these situations
were real so it was sort of it was sort
of um
like heartwarming in that way
yeah especially with like the at the end
with the art gallery the women who all
kind of like
comfort you oh my gosh those women they
smelled so good and they
they were so kind they were like the
softest ladies and
yeah they were so lovely um so yeah
everybody i was very surprised by
it's a it's a big statement but i was
surprised by humanity in general in
shooting the movie which was
which is not the takeaway i expected
that's such a great takeaway to have
um yeah i know quickly shifting from bad
trip for a little bit
uh i'm a big fan of bones and i'm
wondering if
there have been any conversations about
returning to that world about some kind
of revival
or anything like that oh my gosh um
i don't know that's a really good
question not that i've heard
but i feel like those things usually
come together pretty quickly
i think scheduling would probably be the
most uh
probably the most difficult thing
because everybody's off doing other
things but
um it would really be funny and and
fun to revisit that i'm sure um i just i
talked to emily
yesterday and tamara and john francis
daley and
michael grant all those guys were all
very in touch so
um i'm sure it would just be a question
of wrangling everybody together
but who knows anything can happen
awesome thanks so much for your time
appreciate it yeah thank you